and last but not least of course it's
also the learnings and what learning is
exactly you'll get out of it will also
depend on the type of program that you
do so the one thing of course are the
lectures the input that you get here you
of course it will benefit most if you
have don't have a business background
yet so if you're for instance an
engineer I've never attended a business
lecture this will then of course be
really great and eye-opening for you for
me personally I already did have some
business education so still learn
something new but probably the biggest
takeaway from their perspective was
really the cultural awareness so for me
having spent half of the program in
Singapore traveling to lots of Asian
countries in Southeast Asia spending
several weeks in China for instance the
experiences that I did there the
cultural sensitivity that this gave to
me was really eye-opening for me I took
so much away from that and which was a
fundamental part of for my personal
learning experience